كما يشارك الاف من
الاسرائيليين من مدن وبلدات عده في غلاف
غزه في مسيره انطلقت قبل ايام من تل ابيب
في طريقها لمقر الحكومه الاسرائيليه في
القدس المسيره اقتربت من الكنيست ومن مقار
المكاتب الحكوميه في القدس الغربيه ويطالب
المتظاهرون بالافراج عن الاسرى والرهائن
المحتجزين في غزه كما تشير التقديرات
الاوليه الى مشاركه عش عرات الالاف من
الاسرائيليين في هذه المسيره رافعين
لافتات بصور واسماء الرهائن في غزه
ومرددين شعارات ابرزها جميعا الان الان في
اشاره الى ضروره عمل الحكومه على العمل
فورا لاطلاق سراح الرهائن الان ودفعه
واحده معنا الان من القدس مراسلتنا نجوان
سمري نجوان كنت تتابعين هذه المسيره هل من
معلومات جديده بشانها
تفضلي نعم ليلى يعني المسيره تقترب من هذا
الموقع حيث ستنتهي
بمظاهره ضخمه في هذا الشارع تحديدا الذي
يضم غالبيه المقار الحكوميه من مكتب
الحكومه والكنيست ووزارات ع من هذا الشارع
ستاتي هذه المسيره بدانا نرى اعداد من
المشاركين في هذه المسيره يصلون بالقرب من
وزاره الخارجيه الشوارع مغلقه بالكامل في
هذه المنطقه ليلى استعدادا لوصول هذه
المسيره التي خرجت او انطلقت من مدينه تل
ابيب يوم الاحد الماضي وكان بها عدد قليل
جدا من المشاركين لكن على مدار خمسه ايام
توقف هذه المسيره في بلدات ومدن اسرائيليه
عده في الطريق بين تلبيب والقدس لحشد
اعداد من المؤيدين والداعمين لهذا الحراك
الذي يطالب بالافراج عن الاسرى
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في قطاع غزه راينا
في في مداخلات سابقه عشرات الالاف منهم
يشاركون في هذه المسيره التي جابت شوارع
مدينه القدس تحديدا المح اذا سمحت لي
نجوان اذا سمحت لي هذا يعني الرقم عندما
نتحدث عن عشرات الالاف من الذي يقول انهم
عشرات الالاف طبعا هناك ممكن يكون 20 الف
ممكن يكون 70 الف هل هناك تقديرات اكثر
دقه من الجانب الاسرائيلي على الاقل او
مما تعرفين انت
تفضلي نعم هي تقديرات للشرطه الاسرائيليه
وفقا لما جاء في البيان الاولي ولكن
بطبيعه الحال بعد انتهاء هذه المسيره سيتم
الاعلان بشكل رسمي عن العدد المحدد
للمشاركين ولكن بعد وصول هذه المسيره
لمحيط منطقه المقار الحكوميه كان هناك
اعلان من قبل الشرطه الاسرائيليه بان
عشرات الالاف من المشاركين بداوا يصلون
الى هذه المنطقه وبالتالي سنعرف اكثر
العدد المحدد بكل الاحوال الاعداد كبيره
جدا قياسا بما رايناه حتى الان هي المسيره
الاكبر ايه والمظاهره الاكبر في مدينه
القدس القدس لم تشهد هذا الحراك بعد كانت
هناك في بعض الاحيان خيام لبعض المعتصمين
لكن كمظاهر كبيره ليلى هي المظاهره الاولى
في مدينه القدس قباله مكاتب الحكومه
الاسرائيليه والكنيست الاسرائيلي منذ
اندلاع الحرب بدا هذا الحراك تحديدا في
منطقه تلبيب تم تغيير اسم ميدان كامل في
تل ابيب من ميدان متحف تل ابيب
هنا عا
تبات المت بالمطالبه بالافراج عن الاسر
الاسرائيليين يكون هناك عاده العائلات
وداعم لهم وتكون هناك في كل يوم سبت
مظاهره كبيره يشارك فيها بالبدايه كانت
هناك المئات ثم الالاف لكن في الاسابيع
الاخيره الماضيه وصلت الاعداد بالفعل الى
عشرات الالاف في تل ابيب لكن هذه هي المره
الاولى التي تشهد فيها مدينه
من المظهرين
وحج والمطالبين للحكومه الاسرائيليه
بالعمل والتعجيل الاساس هو الاسراع
والتعجيل بابرام صفقه تبادل لان الوقت
ينفد هذا هو الشعار الان الان والجميع
الان قبل ان ينفذ الوقت قبل ان يكون الوقت
موقت العائلات تخشى بان يعود نعم لاطراف
عديده وعلى راسها نتنياهو لان الوقت ايضا
بالنسبه له يعني الكثير الان اشكرك نجوان
سمري على هذه التفاصيل والمتابعه للمسيره
شكرا